He gives zero fucks.
Your Ratha drove,
rode to the experience.
Absolutely.
It's um,
hey,
get back to what you call the cupbearer,
which is a double wrist lock.
Uh,
when it shows over with,
have I ever showed you how Karl gotch did?
It blows the variation the car.
Gosh,
you'd be planning on putting me into submission.
Why don't you show me on Brian?
You could tap him.
I would be glad I've heard.
I've heard nevertheless allow you to put someone into a position.
Oh No,
no.
[inaudible] have a guy like Brian.
Brian,
you're so gummy.
You won't even get hurt if he said it's a sexual thing,
but not for you.
Believe me.
You won't even get a wet.
You know,
it's uh,
they,
they do the Kubara there and they grabbed the risks.
Are you going to let them do it too?
Oh,
you're crazy.
Okay.
What does he have to do?
Oh,
I don't believe so.
Please be nice to him.
He's very delicate.
Don't hurt them.
Okay.
The Camorra like that.
Yeah.
We're not going to do this.
This is what you do to put the pain on,
right.
Okay.
Now.
Here's the difference.
I grow it here.
Now tell me what it is.
Oh,
you're doing a wrist lock as well.
I see
the tap too
outrageous.
What you're doing is you're attacking the wrist as well as that.
What it is,
I turn it [inaudible] instead of going like this,
it's just straight up.
Oh,
I see.
Okay,
so you just,
you have his hand twisted around and he's got no strength to get out of that.
That way your hands all twisted up like that.
Very hard to get any strength.
Right.
I won't do it.
He's gonna do it.
He could put his hand between my legs and a roll me back,
but see that way
don't let him see you doing that.
It's going to hurt you
here.
I'm not going to do it.
Okay.
He's going to do it
instead of going like this,
you know,
you're just go up.
Is it harder to hold onto it that way?
It seems like,
especially with a sweaty hand might be a little difficult,
but good for Mae.
Right?
If you could get your thumb inside the glove and they don't catch you.
It depends how big your hand is called.
God,
she had a big hand and very small woman hands.
Yeah.
Brian is a very small woman.
Hands you get let go of him.
Gene,
you're making me uncomfortable.
I feel like you're gonna hurt my little buddy.
Get out of there.
Brian.
Quick.
You just wrestling with a crocodile.
You fuck awesome.
Did it felt scary?
No,
no,
no.
I can see where you could just,
just no reason to be a bully and that's what makes you feel good.
Zero is perfect.
My arm feels cold.
Will you broke a Chino Jean?
The bell broker.
You should be honored here,
one of,
and can you autograph it?
And a lot of graph your cats don't let anybody get behind you.
Yeah.
You don't ever have let people do that again,
Huh?